an insufferable power-hungry bureaucrat
testifies before Congress we examine the
most nauseating highlights and get to
the heart of this impeachment battle
which is not really about left versus
right or Democrat versus Republican it's
about slavery versus freedom
technocratic tyranny versus
constitutional self-government if we
want to keep our liberties there's only
one option the deep state must be
defeated
then the ACLU celebrates international
men's day by tweeting about menstruation
the daughter of Britain's first gay dads
explains why she's happy that her
boyfriend is now dating her father and
the governor of South Dakota tells the
nation that she's on meth all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
what a day we have so much to get to
let's get this out of the way first
because I don't want to harp for too
long on impeachment I do want to get the
highlights out here though so let's get
this out of the way if you haven't been
paying attention and I know you haven't
because nobody has been paying attention
to this stupid impeachment battle there
were another two major witnesses
yesterday and there were another two
witnesses that testified the Trump did
not engage in a quid pro quo so right
now Democrats are Battin what over five
conservatives in the Trump
administration batting a thousand the
two people who testified yesterday were
Kurt Volker and Tim Morrison Kurt Volker
is a diplomat US Special Representative
for Ukraine before that he was
ambassador to NATO for Barack Obama so
this is a guy who's had a career in
diplomacy that's Volcker and Tim
Morrison was the or is the senior
official on the NSC who is testifying he
was the the boss of that Lieutenant
Colonel vind Minh who's going to play a
big role in this in this testimony so
you got Volcker you got Morrison both of
those guys admit it clear as day on
television for all the world to see if
anybody were paying attention the Trump
did not engage in any quid pro quo or
any bribery or any treason here they are
did you crane open investigation into
the Biden's mr. Morrison that's my
knowledge brand ambassador Volcker not
to my knowledge either did either of you
ever have any evidence of quid pro quo
miss Morrison a master Volcker I did not
any evidence of bribery no ma'am no no
any evidence of treason no ma'am no
evidence of treason with that I yield
back there it is
whatever headline you see today and I
know that you're gonna see a lot of
headlines in the New York Times and The
Washington Post the walls are closing in
Trump's days are numbered wrongdoing
whistleblowers just remember that
testimony okay another two key star
witnesses Volcker and Morrison did the
president engage in any bribery no did
he engage in
quid pro quo no did Ukraine even
investigate the Biden's no was there any
treason no nothing nada
Nuala throw it away got nothing so they
admit in their testimony the Trump
didn't commit any impeachable offense
also by the way same day Lieutenant
General Keith Kellogg who is vice
president Pence's national security
adviser he released a statement
yesterday saying that he was on
president Trump's phone call with
Ukraine on July 25th that was the call
with a Ukraine president szalinski and
he said he heard nothing wrong he heard
nothing improper there but that doesn't
matter to the Democrats favor witness
yesterday a gentleman by the name of
Lieutenant Colonel vind men we will get
to him not even what he has to say about
impeachment because he has nothing
interesting to say about impeachment
what he has to say tells us everything
about the deep state which is really the
heart of this impeachment battle before
we get to that I've got to thank our
friends over at honey you know how much
I love honey what is honey honey is a
free browser extension that
automatically applies the best promo
codes whenever you shop online this
means that you are always getting the
best deals without even trying on over
20,000 sites that's Amazon that's ebay
that's Target that's pretty much
wherever you are going to shop it's very
simple it's as simple as it comes honey
saves you money honey is found it's over
10 million members over a billion
dollars in savings
honey supports over 20,000 stores online
it has over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on the Google Chrome store I've
been using honey since before this show
existed I've been using honey since
before the Daily wire existed and when
it comes time for that holiday shopping
that is when you are going to especially
love honey you know honey's been with us
so long on this show that they still use
promo code cough fa c OV e fe fe if you
are buying gifts this holiday season you
need honey if you're if you're not
buying gifts somehow I don't know how
you probably know somebody who is doing
Messala let them know about honey
it's the best way to get the best price
it's free to use installs in two clicks
get honey for free right now and join
honey calm slash cough FA Co V Fe Fe get
a little nostalgia and throw back this
holiday season with that promo code join
honey calm that's that's what you got to
type in join honey calm slash cough FA
CoV f e f e so everything you need to
know on the heart the meat of whether
Trump committed an impeachable offense
we already got to we've already heard
the testimony we've heard it yesterday
we aren't at the day before that we're
we've we've got that okay no quid pro
quo no wrongdoing but let's look at the
impeachment itself lieutenant-colonel
vind Minh who has been talking to the
lawyers and he's been talking to the
whistleblower and he's been one of these
operatives who's been trying to stir up
impeachment the whole time he's
testifying before Congress and
representative Nunez begins to grill him
but VIN Minh won't have any of it VIN
Minh cuts him off and says excuse me mr.
representative you better use my proper
military rank mr. VIN Minh you testified
in your deposition that you did not know
the whistleblower ranking member at
South lieutenant-colonel Viet Minh
please I live lieutenant colonel bemmon
you testified in the deposition that you
did not know who the whistleblower was
all right I do not know who the
whistleblower is give me a break first
of all I don't believe him for a second
that he doesn't know who the
whistleblower is I think we all know who
the whistleblowers I think it's Eric cha
ramela as was reported by real clear
investigations and I especially think
that guy knows who he is because that
guy talked to him allegedly reportedly I
have to catch all of my all of my
assertions here it certainly would
appear to be the case but let's get to
this this military rank lieutenant its
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh by the way
in Congress all of the congressmen are
referred to as representative that's
their official title and yet when you
hear them speak to one another it's
always mr and ms and
it's the this military rank thing it's
it's pathetic I mean no disrespect to
the military when I say that actually a
number of very high-profile soldiers and
sailors and seals special operators
called out lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh
on this and said it was ridiculous what
he did Tim Kennedy active Green Beret
Special Forces sniper tweeted out quote
correcting a civilian about how to be
addressed is a for-sure way to make
everyone in the military think you are a
then he uses a little profanity which
I'll refrain from here but say yeah say
hygiene product is what he's referring
to
mark Geist who fought the Battle of
Benghazi said that VIN Minh is a
disgrace
Robert o Neill there's a Navy SEAL
credited with firing the shot that
killed Osama bin Laden said quote I wish
the left wouldn't use his uniform to
make him a saint he's an operative with
an agenda Jim Hansen former US Army
Special Forces said quote vind Minh is
the Frank burns of the NSC he corrects
Devon Nunez who called him mister with
the prissy reply it's Lieutenant Colonel
VIN Minh he's right but only a fat face
loser hated by everyone in his unit acts
like that that's that's a Jim Hansen it
is true I mean he is a lieutenant
colonel so you know thank thank you for
your service Lieutenant Colonel and you
deserve to be referred to by your
military title but I got a lot of
friends and family in the military they
would never do anything like that I mean
I just I think of my grandfather might
you know Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh is
an O five that's his rank right my
grandfather was a captain in the Navy oh
six outranks colonel VIN Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh I've never heard him
correct anybody who who would refer to
him as mr. or anything else it's just so
so unseemly it's so unbecoming
especially of an officer in the military
so anyway that kind of sets you up with
who this guy is and you even before he
testified we know that he's he's one of
the people at the heart of stirring up
this whole impeachment controversy we
know he's a jerk turns out he's also a
slimeball what happened here Lieutenant
Colonel Veneman disagreed with the
president's policy on Ukraine so instead
of
bringing up his concerns to his
immediate superior his boss on the NSC
instead of bringing his concerns up to
the president what Lieutenant Colonel
VIN Minh decided to do is go around the
constitutional order go around the
president of the United States go around
his own boss go straight to a lawyer and
tee up this whole impeachment charade
don't take my word for it here is Tim
Morrison this is this is a ving man's
boss on the NSA and by the way Morrison
has made it clear he doesn't want to run
down VIN mennies he's been very reticent
in his testimony but here is Morrison
admitting while he's being grilled that
VIN Minh went around him and stirred up
this whole thing here's his Tim Morrison
you indicated in your deposition that
when you took over the portfolio for dr.
hill July 15th you were alerted to
potential issues in Colonel venom ins
judgment yes
did she relay anything specific to you
specifically to you why she thought that
not not as such it was more of a
overarching statement from her and her
deputy who became my deputy that they
had concerns about judgment during the
deposition I asked you mr. Morrison
whether others raised a concern that mr.
Colonel women may have leaked
information you did ask that yes yeah
and your answer was others that
represented that yes okay and I asked
you whether you were concerned colonel
women did not keep you in the loop at
all times with his official duties yes
and in fact when he went to the National
Security Council lawyers following the
July 25th call he did not first come to
you is that correct correct there you
have it so we know that VIN Minh he had
some problems with this policy and he
went around everybody went to a lawyer
there were concerns that were
represented to Morrison that this guy
had bad judgment that this guy was a
leaker that this guy was really abusing
his
office on the NSC and what I actually
love about this exchange is you can tell
Morris and doesn't want to run the guy
down because he's asked were there what
he actually is asked did I ask you when
we were when you were testifying
previously if there were concerns that
he was a leaker and Morrison leans and
he says yes you did ask me that like
well okay were there concerns that he
was a leaker yes that was represented to
me he's being very cautious in his
testimony but the message is clear this
guy VIN man was a rogue he was a
political operator he was undermining
the policy of the president because as
we're about to find out
lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh didn't care
about the policy of the president he
doesn't think it's the president who
makes policy thinks it's him we'll get
to that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over first leave I love
first leave you know that I love
drinking high quality wine I'm a man of
simple tastes I'm easily satisfied by
the very best and I'm Italian so I've
been drinking wine since I was six years
old I haven't been a member of other
wine clubs before some of them have been
a little disappointing sometimes so I
went into first leaf I had modest
expectations you get started by you take
a first leaf wine quiz and so you can
assess your exact wine drinking
preferences and I've got very particular
preferences so you can do it from
sweetness to wine styles how adventurous
you are that sort of thing
so I clicked on all of that first leaf
then created an introductory six pack of
wine for me all for just $29 so at this
point my expectations were were quite
low all right I thought there's no way
that you're gonna get good wine for $29
and 2995 that they're gonna be able to
to decide what you like these wines by
the way normally go for like $20 a piece
so the bottles arrived I tried them the
wine is superb the wine is excellent I
am I'm not even saying excellent by my
usual I buy a cheap bottle of wine
standards I mean these wines are
excellent buy expensive bottle of wine
standards especially the Reds I found
the Reds were really good what I love
too about first leaf is it doesn't even
just take your word for what you like I
mean it does it plays with your tastes
but very often I know this is true for
me I use words to describe wine that I
don't really that the donee
really apply to the wine so what you do
is you try all the wines then you go on
and you rate them and you say what you
actually ended up liking and then first
leave uses all that data to send even
more wines that you're gonna like even
more so it's the more you use it the
better the wine becomes in fact first
leaf sends out more than 17,000 unique
shipments of wine every single month
because everyone's tastes are different
try first leap swine Club today
I absolutely love it it is we're buying
great wine is simple sign up right now
with my link and you will get an
exclusive intro offer six bottles of
wine very very good one for only 29.95
plus free shipping do it I am enjoy one
on me have a toast to me try this is
what you this is a website try first
leaf calm all one term try first leaf
calm slash Knowles Canada wles six
bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping when you
go to try first leaf calm slash Knowles
canna wles
and I needed I needed a few glasses of
that while I was watching these
impeachment hearings why didn't loot N
and Colonel VIN men express his concerns
to his boss ok vind Minh was the
director of European affairs on the NSC
his boss is Tim Morrison on the MSC why
did he go to a lawyer why did he go
around the official process Jim Jordan
Republican congressman as usual nails
him after the call why didn't you go to
mr. Morrison I went immediately / the /
the instructions from the July 10th
incident I meant went immediately to mr.
Eisenberg after that once I made that my
expressed my concerns it was an
extremely busy week we had a PCC just
finished we had the call and then we had
a deputies meeting which consumed all of
my time I was working extremely long
days oh yeah is that right Lieutenant
Colonel Denman so the reason that you
didn't go to your superiors and follow
the chain of command here when you
wanted to change US policy
single-handedly the reason that you went
to a lawyer instead but you didn't have
time to go to your boss is be
you were really busy that week are you
joking this is like a freshman in
college who didn't finish his term paper
on time making an excuse to his
professor you had time to go to the
lawyer you had time to gin up this whole
conspiracy this whole impeachment hoax
which we've heard is a hoax based on now
what five major witnesses called forth
by Adam Schiff to testify so you had
time to do that but you didn't have time
to go to your boss
give me a break yet you had time to talk
to somebody it wasn't even just the
lawyer he also had to add time didn't
have time to talk to his boss they had
time to talk to the lawyer and he had
time to talk to somebody else in the
murky deep state intelligence community
Jim Jordan pulls that out of him so the
lawyer you not only didn't go to your
boss you said you tried but didn't go to
your boss you went straight to the
lawyer and the lawyer told you not to go
to your boss
no he didn't tell me until why didn't
you go to your direct report mr.
Morrison your response was beat this
page 102 because mr. Eisenberg it told
me to take my concerns to him then I
asked you did miss did mr. Eisenberg
tell you not to report to go around mr.
Morrison and you said actually he did
say that I shouldn't talk to any other
people that right yes but there's a
whole there's a period of time in there
between when I spoke to him and when he
circled back around it wasn't that long
a period of time but it was enough time
for me to enough time do you go to talk
to someone that you won't tell us who it
is right I Bob I've been instructed not
to representative Jordan well here's
what I'm getting the lawyer told you
don't talk to any other people and you
interpret that is not talking to your
boss but you talk to your brother you
talk to the lawyers you talk to
secretary Kent and you talk to the one
guy Adam Schiff won't tell you won't let
us won't let you tell us who he is that
right representing Jordan I did my job
oh what a little weasel this guy is I
love they say so jim jordan says
lieutenant-colonel vin Minh the lawyer
told you not to talk to your boss well
no no he didn't tell me not to talk to
my boss until he told me not to talk to
my boss oh okay and you didn't have time
to talk to anybody right yeah that's
right I didn't have time to talk to
anybody other than your brother and
other than this
actually and other than the
whistleblower and other than all that
you had time to talk to them right and
obviously at this point VIN min has
nothing to say so he just comes out and
says mr. Jordan I did my job no you
didn't do your job you did the opposite
of your job you know what Vin mental
refers to so much throughout this
mindless testimony is how he did go to
the bureaucrats he did go to the
interagency the interagency that's the
term that keeps coming up he did go to
the federal bureaucracy but he didn't go
to his boss he didn't follow the chain
of command he didn't follow the
president's policy the interagency
that's the battle here the president the
elected guys the American people versus
the decisions of the interagency the
federal bureaucracy the deep state this
guy binman
is an operative with an agenda he's just
admitted it himself how do we let's
let's put not to put too fine a point on
it but let's see if this weasel can can
just finally come right out and say what
he really wants to which is that he
believes it is the job of himself
the job of the interagency the job of
the entrenched bureaucracy to make
policy and it's not the job of the
elected president of the United States
is there a process to determine official
US policy yes that is my job is to
coordinate US policy so throughout the
preceding year that I've been on staff I
had undertaken an effort to make sure we
had a cohesive coherent US policy and as
you listened to the call did you observe
whether President Trump was following
the talking points based on the official
US policy counsel the the president
could choose to use the talking points
or not he's the president but they were
not consistent with what I provided yes
the temerity of that response that
response by the way is it is to the
Democratic Council the temerity of the
Democratic Council asking if
lieutenant-colonel vind men made
sure that the President of the United
States was following his talking points
on official US policy just the question
itself the question itself basically
boils down to who makes US policy and
VIN Minh doesn't wait one little second
he says I make US policy no you don't
dude you know what makes us for policy
the President of the United States you
don't get to dictate to the President of
the United States what the policy is and
you don't get to dictate to the
President of the United States what he
should say about what the policy is
you are a functionary you work for him
you should keep your mouth shut and do
what the president of the United States
tells you to do because guess what none
of us elected Lieutenant Colonel VIN
Minh and after that testimony none of us
really seem to like Lieutenant Colonel
VIN Minh not a very likable guy he's a
power-hungry bureaucrat and a Priss
about it too we elected Trump you maybe
you don't like Trump too bad that's your
job do your job VIN Minh thinks that he
makes policy him and the interagency
here's what he said the interagency
policy was to support secretary it was
to support Security Assistance for the
Ukraine hey you know what I think of the
interagency policy when it comes into
conflict with the policy of our duly
represented duly elected representatives
this I think I've lick off underneath my
chin that's what I think he says in in
my position I coordinate with a superb
cohort of interagency porters I bet you
coordinate with the President of the
United States and shut your mouth and do
your job he says quote I'm the point man
for coordinating the interagency I don't
care who you are and I don't care what
your title is I don't care about you
Lieutenant Colonel ventolin I care about
the American people having control over
their own government and you following
the orders of the elected
representatives nobody elected this guy
he wants representative Nunez to have
more respect for his military title how
about Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh show
some respect to his civilian superiors
namely Devon Nunez namely his boss on
the National Security Council namely the
President of the United States in this
country the civilians run the show not
the military I have great respect for
the military
have a ton of respect for VIN Minh but I
have a lot of respect for the military
and by the way most of my pals in the
military know that in this country the
civilians run the show how about the
interagency I got friends who've worked
at the the interagency the good ones are
the ones who know that the civilians run
the show
in particular the elected
representatives not some technocratic
in the deep state okay do you know who
runs the show in this country not any of
the punks like Eric charmella allegedly
who are shredding our Constitution
because they don't like that the
American people elected the wrong
candidate in 2016 this is not even about
the left versus the right this is not
even a bad Democrat versus Republican I
mean it is in so much as the left likes
the entrenched bureaucracy a lot more
than the right tends to but you know
Republicans like the bureaucracy
sometimes too if a Democratic president
right now we're threatening the
technocratic status quo you can bet that
the deep state would be going after them
too this is a major threat to the
country this is a major threat because
it actually transcends partisan
differences in the partisan divide and
it gets right down to the heart of who
we are are we going to be a country
that's run by good experts with nice
ties all well tied up and good-looking
jackets on who nobody elected them and
they don't have any real powers
designated in the Constitution but hey
they know better for us so they're gonna
make us policy and the president he just
better go along with it and by the way
if he doesn't go along with it we're
gonna throw them out of office and who
cares what the American people say
there's that possibility or their
self-government in our constitutional
order we get to decide obviously people
like lieutenant-colonel vid Minh have
made their decision I think we should
probably make another decision the only
way that this is going to resolve itself
is if the deep state is defeated the
deep state the deep state it's a real
thing it's called the bureaucracy you
just saw a major representative of it
right now the deep state does not want
to voluntarily give up power because
what the deep state thinks is that the
electeds come and go political winds
change but they are always going to
we need to seriously deplete their power
I actually like a lot of the agencies in
the bureaucracy I think they do some
good work but they have become far far
too powerful and if they are going to
try to take sovereignty they're gonna
try to take the control of making policy
in the United States away from the
American people they must be defeated
you know that there was the line in
ancient Rome carthago delenda s carthage
must be destroyed the deep state delenda
s it must be defeated if we are to
preserve our self-government all right
we've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube head on over to Daley wire.com
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the and
reclaim ensure you get the bench be sure
you get the Matt Walsh oh you get to ask
questions in the mailbag coming up
tomorrow but if you are craving more of
my soothing mellifluous voice then you
clearly haven't been listening to
another kingdom that's Andrew clavin's
fantasy podcast it's performed by little
ol me you need to go to daily wire.com
subscribe right now to catch up because
on Monday November 25th at 7 p.m.
Eastern 4:00 Pacific drew and I will be
sitting down together to discuss the
final season also we will be taking
subscriber questions from the fans this
live event will be free for everyone to
watch on Facebook and YouTube but only
subscribers will be able to ask the
questions at daily wire.com Plus
subscribers exclusively can watch the
entirety of the series or you can listen
free to the newest episodes on Apple
podcasts go check it out right now you
do not want to miss another Kingdom live
discussion it's happening Monday at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
much more important than a corrupt
bureaucracy trying to steal the
government of the United States is a
story that came out of Great Britain's
see if you can wrap your head around
this the daughter of Britain's first gay
dads says that she is now happy that her
ex-boyfriend is dating her dad try to
there are a lot of parts of this that
you're gonna have to try to work out in
your head first of all what it means to
have Britain's first gay dads these are
two dads on the birth certificate of a
daughter now look I'm no expert on
biology or something I know these things
change every day now but something would
suggest to me that these two men cannot
come together and produce a daughter
seems like some strange gender ideology
has entered here but then then let's
even just say you could do that so this
daughter somehow has two dads that the
daughter had a boyfriend and then she
broke up with the boyfriend and the dads
broke up with each other so much for the
happy ending to a Britain's first gay
dads and then one of the dads starts
dating the boyfriend couldn't be a very
awkward Thanksgiving this year I guess
they don't have Thanksgiving Britain so
the Proby okay
saffron drew it Barlow that is the 19
year old daughter she is openly bisexual
and she dated Scott Hutchinson 25 year
old and she says it was just a big ploy
to keep his sexuality secret and she
wrote on Instagram that her boyfriend is
now dating her father Barry drew Barlow
a Barry Drew Barlow is only one of her
father's according to her birth
certificate her other father is Tony
drew it Barlow
so Barry drew Barlow's 50 years old Tony
drew at Barlow's 55 years old they were
the first couple in England same-sex
couple to be named on a birth
certificate as parents even though
that's obviously impossible
that was 20 years ago the the men Tony
and Barry they were the first same-sex
dads still live happily under one roof
with Scott the 25 year old ex-boyfriend
of the daughter and the daughter and
actually all of their four other
children in the family's Florida mansion
okay Tony one of the first gay dads has
had some deteriorating health since a
cancer diagnosis in 2006 and this
apparently led the two gay dads to drift
apart into a platonic relationship and
then for this other guy Barry to bring
Scott the 25 year old ex-boyfriend into
the relationship and they're all somehow
living together we are seeing two
narratives collide here on the left two
distinct narratives the first narrative
which is the one we've heard for a long
time is that we must redefine marriage
marriage for all of human history
everywhere in the world has had a
meaning which includes sexual difference
we're now told that we have to redefine
marriage to include monogamous same-sex
unions because marriage is the best and
marriage as we understand it is so
wonderful and so to be desired that we
actually in the name of inclusion must
construct or rather reconstruct marriage
to accommodate same-sex couples marriage
is so good so exclusively to be desired
that we actually have to kind of tweak
marriage which has always included
sexual difference to not include sexual
difference but to still sort of look
like marriage to accommodate people with
same-sex attractions because that's the
only way that they can relate prosper
and thrive in society that's the one
narrative the left oldest that's how
they redefined marriage
the second narrative which is what we're
starting to hear now is that there is
nothing better about traditional
marriage and a daddy can boink his
daughters very young boyfriend and
that's a beautiful wonderful thing and
it's brave and special and how dare you
judge another man's family yeah
what hold on you're telling me you think
it's weird that two guys who presented
themselves as America's first gay dads
live under the same roof with the
daughter's ex-boyfriend who is now
dating one of the dads and there are
other four kids is that what you're
saying
you can't have both of those narratives
you can't have both what this shows and
I I really want to point this out you
know how much I hate saying that we told
you so we told you so conservatives were
right the whole time what was the
conservative argument against redefining
marriage according to the left the
conservative argument is we hate people
we hate people with different sexual
preferences we're mean old conservatives
that's what the left up but of course
that wasn't the argument here was the
conservative argument against redefining
marriage was not in any way disdainful
of homosexuals or people with any sort
of odd sexual preferences it just said
that marriage has a meaning that sexual
difference is essential to marriage
always has been always will be
everywhere in the world
if you radically redefine marriage this
was the conservative argument if you
radically redefine marriage you're not
actually improving marriage and you're
not actually making marriage more
inclusive what you're doing is
destroying marriage because you're
you're cracking the essential definition
of it and then you're watering it down
so much that it doesn't mean anything
anymore the conservative argument is
that the redefinition of marriage would
not make society more orderly would not
bring people into the institution of
marriage but it would actually just
weaken what is the fundamental basis of
social order which is marriage and we
were right we were right told you so but
the left doesn't care about the
consistency here what the left does is
they just move right down along that
slippery slope and then they pretend
that it's crazy to think there'd be a
slippery slope in the first place
okay the first the first gay dads as
they're known in England just split up
in a profoundly troubling way this is
not an indictment of all homosexual
relationships or couples not by a long
shot but it does raise questions about
the redeath
in a marriage when these when these two
gentlemen decided to shack up and and
redefine marriage and and childhood and
all these things we were told that we
had to think this was a fairytale ending
happily ever after these two men just
want to be together and brought into the
institution of marriage and have a
family together just like you and me
isn't that so beautiful brings a tear to
my eye it didn't happen though did it
that's not what happened at all and they
didn't even just divorce like normal
people in modernity okay I think divorce
is terrible too but it's not even like
they just kind of split up and went
their own way they're like living
together in this bizarre arrangement
that is profoundly disorderly and the
left doesn't care the left doesn't care
okay so the left has pretty much wrecked
to marriage successfully at this point
and I'm not I'm not blaming homosexuals
for this I'm only blaming the left
because it didn't begin with redefining
marriage to include same-sex couples it
began with free love and it began in
particular with no-fault divorce that
was a pretty serious blow against
marriage then you got the redefinition
of marriage that finished it off now the
left is on to destroying sex itself not
the even the act of sex but the the
meaning of sex biological sex which
brings us to international men's day how
do you think the ACLU of the American
Civil Liberties Union ironically named
how do you think they celebrated
international men's day one day to
celebrate men or at least international
men I don't know if that means you know
we're talking about sort of exotic types
of men this is what the ACLU tweeted
quote there's no one way to be a man men
who get their periods are men men who
get pregnant and give birth are men
trans and non-binary men belong
international men's day they celebrate
international men's day by talking about
menstruation and I you know I've
actually they inspired me so I'd like to
just point out right now once and for
all standing up for civil rights
standing up for inclusion and tolerance
there's no one way to be a human okay
humans with eight arms and three hearts
our human humans who choose to scurry
along the seafloor so that they don't
swim and stop one of their hearts from
beating or human ok humans who are
octopuses belong happy international
human day and how dare you dear you
suggest that octopuses aren't real
humans because they are ok that's what
this is about this is why I point out
that so much of the left's plans are not
about redefining or not about improving
or not about making more inclusive the
institutions that they go into the left
destroys the institutions it goes into
when it comes to destroying men I'm not
blaming people with gender dysphoria and
I'm not blaming women when it comes to
destroying marriage I'm not blaming
homosexuals I'm not blaming anybody else
when it comes to destroying other
institutions like the university for
instance I'm not blaming liberal
education I'm not blaming the university
itself I am blaming the left because
that's what the left does the left
crawls into institutions like little
octopuses without any vertebrate you
know it just kind of no bones it just
sneaks into these institutions and all
of its little tentacles go out and it
hollows them out from within so that
what you have is a facade and you can
kind of tell it's a cracked and broken
facade of the institution but within
it's totally rotted like the
universities what we look now to the
elite universities in this country they
might look sort of like what the
universities were they are no longer the
universities when we look at the
institution of marriage sort of looks
like Mayor but it not really we look at
men look if if you celebrate
international men's trade by celebrating
periods you've lost the narrative we are
not talking about men anymore it is so
destructive and what we need to do is
conservatives you
get rid of this absurd lie that the left
pushes forward that they're trying to
improve and make more inclusive these
institutions they don't give a damn
about that they don't give a damn about
homosexuals they don't give a damn about
transsexuals they don't give a damn
about education what they want is power
and something that stops them from
taking power are these institutions that
keep us away from being just atomized
individuals totally helpless before and
over powerful overly powerful government
tyrannical government you might say
institutions like marriage institutions
like biology frankly there are parts of
our nature human nature they want to
break human nature itself that's been
the goal of the left since Karl Marx
it's all just about power and we have to
resist that I mean look you can see it
politically you can see it in the name
of impeachment they're saying we need to
overrun all of our norms of government
all our constitutional order we need to
run roughshod over centuries of American
history to unprecedented actions such as
the removal of this president for
anything first of all much less a phone
call with Ukraine where he said nothing
wrong according to the key witnesses the
left tells you we have to do that in the
name of inclusivity in the name of
righteousness in the name of virtue they
don't care about any of that there
they're willing to wreck the
foundational pillars of the country if
it'll just give them a little bit more
power and we've got to stop them they
must be defeated before we go I have to
mention the South Dakota governor South
Dakota Governor Christie know'm has
identified a key problem in this country
actually a key problem that has taken
away a lot of our Liberty and making us
more vulnerable I'm not talking about
political activities I'm talking about
drugs I'm talking specifically about
meth there is a meth epidemic in the
country and Kristi Noem Republican
governor of South Dakota wants to do
something about it so she's launching a
public awareness campaign the public
awareness campaign is called
I'm on meth here she is this campaign is
going to be about solutions and hope and
how every single one of us in South
Dakota can partner to be on meth
really the tagline is I'm on meth and
what it's talking about is that each one
of us no matter who we are
they were on the case of meth that we're
protecting our family we're protecting
our friends for protecting our
communities from this epidemic that we
see and that we're all going to be
taking some responsibility and battling
it and making sure that it's not going
to have a place here in our state
the campaign is called I'm on meth this
is something so hilarious it's out of a
Parks and Rec episode it's like you
couldn't if you scripted that in a Parks
and Rec episode they'd say that's too
on-the-nose come on you got to back off
a little bit here on the one hand this
is a hilariously outrageous tagline is
I'm on meth you have the governor of
cezzah go to saying hey guys I'm on meth
and you know what we're all on meth and
that's a good thing so it's ridiculous
and hilarious on the other hand it
worked I actually think it's a pretty
great tagline it works because we are
talking now about meth because the
governor of South Dakota did something
outrageous and hilarious and now now
we're talking about it we should be
talking about it you know all of the
focus in this drug epidemic in the
country has been on opioids which are a
major problem they're a huge problem in
the country the most law enforcement
agents actually think that meth is the
bigger threat across the country
overdose deaths involving meth have more
than quadrupled since 2011 actually just
between 2011 and 2017 it's probably up
even more now
admission to treatment facilities for
meth are up 17% in that time
hospitalizations related to meth jumped
by about 245 percent from 2008 to 2015
two hundred forty five percent
throughout the West throughout the
Midwest there was a survey of law
enforcement officials 70 percent of law
enforcement agencies say the meth is
their biggest drug threat a bigger
problem then opioids so we should pay
attention to that I actually
this this governor a lot of credit for
an inventive way to do it especially in
South Dakota which I visited South
Dakota before it doesn't get the most
attention of all US states small
population kind of tucked away up there
in the north and so I think she did a
great job I tip my hat to her I'm glad
that she's on meth I'm glad that we're
all on meth and hopefully we can fix the
meth problem before we go also good news
for people to judge big news for people
who judge so we talked yesterday about
how an Iowa first in the nation first
caucus state P Budaj is now leading by
nine somehow not only is it not Biden
anymore not only is it not warmed it's
Pete
mayor Pete pastor Pete Budaj the fake
the fake pastor who tells all Christians
that they're not Christian if they
believe in Christianity the Buddha
judges up according to one poll which by
the way is an outlier poll in another
very important early primary state that
is the state of New Hampshire so again
take this with a little bit of a grain
of salt this is the st. Anselm College
survey center bowl of only 255 likely
Democratic primary voters in New
Hampshire only 255 but you got to
remember it's New Hampshire and I think
there are only about 256 people in New
Hampshire so it's you know that's
probably like almost the whole state
showed that Pete buddy judge is
supported by 25 percent of the
Democratic primary electorate there now
holds a 10-point lead in New Hampshire
over Joe Biden and Liz Warren who were
tied for second and 15 percent the
sample size is too small to draw serious
conclusions here but it does show that
all of the momentum is with Pete Budaj
that's where all of the momentum is
going in even the Democratic primary
field why is that it comes back to what
we've been talking about all day it
comes back to this power grab it comes
back to the radicalization of the left
it comes back to impeachment because
there are people even on the Left even
among Democrats who say that the left
has gone too far that they don't want
their institutions to be completely
destroyed when people judges gay married
but be booted judge is portraying
himself now at least as the
traditionalist
candidate as the more moderate
candidates going for that Joe Biden Lane
and the left is saying okay alright we
need we need to slow this down a little
bit we don't want to completely run
roughshod over our institutions
including or federal government
including the presidency we don't want
to just have these coup d'etat these
cooze in all of our our fundamental
institutions in America we want to slow
down a little bit this is why very few
Americans are watching the impeachment
proceedings this is why very very few
people are tuning into that at all
because it's just gone too far the
narrative is so divorced from reality at
this point that even even among the left
you're seeing the more moderate
candidates come out now can we survive
this can we survive the attempt to
destroy the building blocks of our
society we're seeing that play out right
now 24 hours a day on cable news during
these impeachment hearings if we want to
preserve anything like our
constitutional order anything like our
self-government anything like our
constitutional liberties these
technocratic tyrants must be defeated
this destructive left this this
destructive bureaucracy must be taken
down hope we can do it that's our show
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
nul show come back tomorrow see that
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation